islam net is establishing a masjid and a
community center if you donate to build
this masjid allah build a house for you
in jannah with bricks of gold and silver
every person who prays in this masjid
every child that memorized the quran you
will inshallah sharing that reward
donate now guys and do not delay
[Music]
assalamu alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah yes
it's been a long time me hijab and this
so far but uh a special video bringing
us here today it's this movie that's
been circulating i personally just
wanted to ignore it i spoke to some
brothers that i know
but
what was
what the interest that i had was
basically what does the shia communities
have to say about this that's what i
really want to know how'd you get it
because i didn't know what they have to
say would tell me a lot about what they
actually think so i was sent a video
randomly i was just waiting here i was
waiting to go out and this video let's
watch it for ourselves so these are two
individuals we don't know if they're
surely
within the uh he's very controversial
based off of that there's a lot of don't
watch it don't do this don't do that so
to be honest if you were both very
excited uh to actually see that
something was being done in honor of uh
actually excited when you see that
so what you just said that i'm assuming
this issue
okay maybe yeah maybe no yeah it
probably is yeah i mean they said within
this yeah
so let's not this is very important he
said we're going to see is it a bad
depiction or is a good depiction it's
very important yeah don't forget what
you just said
i mean again it wasn't entirely bad but
i guess when you when you're talking
about a project that's related to
you have very high expectations yeah and
you know what i think that
i would give it a higher rating just
because of the storytelling the story
itself is incredible i think the story
itself is what makes the movie good but
there's a lot of defaults in the movie
yeah so i mean i i would say the first
thing for me personally i would say this
is probably the biggest objection that i
had when i was watching the movie um was
the fact that the prophet and his face
were so they were showing it
yes let's talk about that for a second
obviously within shay uh a lot of
foot here of the shia they allow that
yeah you'll see here you'll see the
depictions of alibi live and stuff like
the thing it's out of that you know you
refrain from showing the physical
characteristics
to
um
herself um i feel like they could have
done a better job uh focusing in on her
story specifically i felt like they kind
of bounced around um a little too much
um rather than just focus on the level
uh
so i think if they took that approach uh
to just kind of share her story
specifically kind of go through her life
and uh
you know in the movie they portrayed it
you know within two lines uh it was a
very quick scene but the real story is a
very very long and in-depth and powerful
story so i think if they focus on the
story uh as opposed to trying to tell
entirely
i'm assuming that these filmmakers were
so
they're so enraged in uh hate
that apparently these people watched it
that they didn't even talk about the
story of fatima that they were just
focused on just vilifying everyone else
because they're saying like come on the
whole story is about her and all you're
showing is
as far as i know but it seems like but
yeah also you know this whole this whole
narrative of and i'll mention that my
own video but i'll mention here again
of fatima being they didn't mention that
clearly this shows that they've got
their shiites right yeah but they didn't
mention the fact that the whole story
was made up okay good which is very good
this whole story of
coming into the house and killing fatima
and the baby being killed and then she
going out apparently yeah some some time
after making a speech whilst her husband
was cowering or stuff that which which
depicts sally and and father men are
very bad like of course
yeah we will always love and respect him
it's a part of our religion yeah i mean
they don't need to yeah
it's fine we'll see on the judgment
who's right and who's wrong but the
thing is this is a historical so
so let me get this right so
these two share this uh individuals here
they are basically giving their feedback
on a story that isn't real
yeah exactly it's very important so
let's carry on because this as we see
mythology
yeah movie is called the lady of heaven
yeah they don't really uh focus and much
on her which is odd uh one thing i
dislike about the movie is when uh put
the cloak on him um
in relation to like their standing with
the prophet
religion and i like how the the
grandmother had a very very affectionate
maryland yeah i was actually sharing a
story with the kid
that's how it was you kind of um up with
these notions of our minds and our
prophet and these teachings that they're
very hard on you there's always a lesson
for kids and grown-ups to be derived
from their lives and do the things that
they say and the things that they do so
overall we're happy that the story was
told um there's a lot of things that
happened after the prophet
so okay so you're happy with the story
was told
but
the story is it's like it's like me
watching superman
because
it's worse than that because at least
superman is a there's a moral it's it
follows a certain structure there's
thought put into this the story that
they've put in these uh books
which narrates that fatima was killed by
amar
and all these things
i mean this is this is the biggest this
this movie is dissolving no no one
second this movie was aimed to dishonor
the companions but in reality i don't
know if they show this in the movie as
if um
is coming in and killing her and ali is
there this is the greatest dishonor to a
lion of islam ali
and like this is someone the enemies
would ya shake
and you're telling me this man
is in his house watching his wife being
brutally killed
so this is the greatest dishonor to imam
ali yaya if you hold them to that status
which we do
the greatest disrespect is that you're
telling me someone like ali nadiran a
warrior
a lion is going to be there and somebody
comes and snaps his wife out of the
black kills and he kills her he kills
her and he's like what can i do about it
the greatest dishones and you guys are
acting and reacting to this as if it's a
true story that's what bewilders me bro
like madness
stupid like this being made or there are
are sources out there so when there are
narratives like this being pushed um one
just has to you know then do the
research on their own uh it's meant to
spark a uh curiosity of the individual
in order that they go and they do the
research on their own so this is the
shadow i'm glad that it was told it
reflected the oppression that the
activity faced after the prophet's
so
would you like if the sunnis made a film
and depicted um i don't know not that we
can we wouldn't
yeah imagine imagine we did the same
with the twelve mountains or um
these individuals that you guys hold you
know uh love to you and imagine if we do
that would you go and say oh it's
freedom expression you should go and
worship me would you say that you
wouldn't say that you know you wouldn't
say that so why is it with this because
to me when you say this to me it's like
wow okay this your community i'm not
judging based on two individuals but you
guys
don't seem like yeah
you know you don't seem that they're
laughing they don't care about
disrespecting sunnis no exactly so to me
when i see two shias doing this look
i've had she was coming to me and said
do you do to philosophy
of you guys i don't yeah i see you guys
as my brother my brothers and sisters
i'll be very honest with you unless you
come and tell me that it's going to
start cursing aisha and her and i'll say
to my my friend to you later
the scholars make that decision that
anyone that insults the mother of the
belief is a kafir yeah so the thing is
we are trying to see from the shia and
you two i'm not gonna say your
representative but what you're saying to
me is worrying like if you guys are
saying this
i don't know what to expect from the
whole sheikh community i'll be honest
with you like are you guys really this
brainwashed to the level that you're
saying that to depict the prophet it's
you you mentioned that which right they
saw them depicting is wrong et cetera
and you are coming in and telling us the
prophet sallallahu selden his companions
that he lived fought with battled like
they everything these guys the stuff
they did and you're here this movie is
basically tarnishing the image lying
about against them
if you are so concerned about the
prophet's image being shown which we all
should what about his companions how
they being degraded and insulted against
well they don't care about the the
bigger bigger picture here is for them
as well
this as they write it's not just
controversial this guy's an extremist
yes
yeah he's an extreme terrorist yeah he's
an individual who's actually got
individuals militias
on his behalf
it's the equivalent of us taking someone
from isis it's actually i would say way
worse to be honest in my view taking
someone from isis their scripts and and
praising it and talking of it and just
saying it's good that it shows this
without the other you know it shows you
that to be quite honest with you
the the standards are completely messed
up skewed up and and quite honest it
shows you the level of disrespect that
now individuals from the shia community
think that they can give us don't trust
us imagine imagine i don't try this
imagine
which is actually enough to do us
represent us doing a video like this and
then we go oh you know it's free you
know if you want to watch it you know it
was good don't get comfortable don't get
comfortable yeah
try and depict our sacred symbols in a
manner and then just coming out
nonchalantly speaking yeah yeah don't
get don't get comfortable because
believe me that's going to create some
rift that we don't want in this uh in
the community exactly
is a different topic but just in the
sense from a film perspective i just
wish that maybe they wish that they
focus a little bit more on letting
history speak for itself as opposed to
trying to paint
here you're basically saying you don't
need to make the person bad tell the
story because in the story he's bad yeah
that's what you're trying to say
yeah exactly so you're saying basically
it's pictured as a black man right i
don't know yeah i think isn't that
correct the picture with black skin and
stuff like so all the antagonists are
depicted in black skin how comes you
didn't say anything about that yeah
nothing's gonna say anything about that
yeah is this is that casual racism that
you've got now going on in the shia
community is that what's happening yeah
exactly let's watch the last
15 seconds
these people man they think they should
come out we need voices of condemnation
yeah don't come out and speak about the
sunni people like that and try and say
don't do that because you wouldn't like
it the other way around yeah exactly you
wouldn't like it some other person come
and start from from we wouldn't do it
because you know we were in there
because we hold them sacred as well
exactly but let's say someone from
another religion starts to do with ali
yeah what you guys did with our mother
yeah just think of it like that yeah
would you and would you like if you come
and say you know it's we can't see
anyway so imagine if i was an atheist
and i said oh you know what um it's you
know you're born free you know
you would hate it this is the issue with
this whole freedom of nonsense yeah when
it's done towards other person this what
it shows me that you two
these two individuals you actually um
promote it you promote it don't come and
say to me you are promoting it you are
happy with it that's what you're showing
me you are using certain
words here and there but you are
basically saying yeah you know go and
watch see what they really did and
basically in international is the story
true it's not true man
it's fake it's not true give us the
evidence yes yes that's just not true
yeah that's not true exactly but yeah
that's it so that's it wrong sisters you
guys make your decision inshallah uh we
don't want anyone to go send hate to
them we're just telling you straight up
it worries us to see the shia community
like i said i want to judge them based
on these two individuals very concerning
very concerning and we will inshallah
not allow these movies or these filth
what was the name
to cause um you know for shias and
sunnis to fight each other we don't want
to go down that route they're trying to
do that and we're not how we do that you
know when they share the the the
the
place of worship was attacked
we went there yeah me you and shah
absolutely we actually went there you
know why because we said you know the
person who did it he didn't say she has
sunni yeah so we went there so no one
can come and tell us oh you hate she has
this kind of nonsense but if you're
going to come to us with that yeah you
know it's true yeah we will see a
different side to us and when i'm on a
different side i'm talking about you
know showing your true colors that's
right that's right until next time
islam net is establishing a masjid and a
community center if you donate to build
this masjid allah build a house for you
in jannah with bricks of gold and silver
every person who prays in this masjid
every child that memorized the quran you
will inshallah sharing that reward
donate now guys and do not delay
[Music]